hi i am eric andre and i'm here with
buzzfeed to read your thirst tweets
number one every day i fall more and
more in love with eric andre and that's
a beautiful thing
i am also in love with you internet
stranger let's french eric andre more
like eric
andre because he is always looking like
a snack
yes you get me moist zaddy
real reckon that's real can't spell
american dream without eric andre
and i think that's beautiful yes pure
coincidence by the way that
my name is in the middle of the american
dream the american dream
also isn't a real thing that's like a
crockish patriotic propaganda from like
the 30s or something like what's the
american dream
capitalism it only works for like four
people
can eric andre be my daddy that's it
that's the thirst tweet
uh yeah i could be your daddy anytime
i'll be your mommy why not and your
little baby i'll wear a
diaper and you can slap me for big fat
i'm uncomfortable all at this to have
sex with eric andre once i have sex with
eric i will leave everybody
alone okay show me what you're working
with owen i know i can't say your handle
but i could say your first name
let me see those holes i wouldn't eric
andre how many likes until i could suck
your toes
zero my man pucker up my toes are filthy
haven't clipped my nails since the
beginning of the pad
damn it i got pterodactyl feet can't
sleep and thinking about a threesome
with eric andre and hannibal burris
hannibal will probably take the most
convincing out of the three of us
i would assume i don't want to speak for
him since i've been tweeting about my
desires whenever i wake up i want
nothing more than for eric andre to
destroy my insides live on the eric
andre show holy [ __ ]
your wish is back to matt oh god i've
never been more
wet in my life at eric andre i would eat
nutella off of your nipples
xx sure i love hazelnut i'm gonna
hazel nut when you lather that nutella
on playboy ericandre shows equivalent to
just a 15-minute orgasm
yes i mean that's in the eye of the
beholder i'd orgasm on like
bad acid and road with tessen but i
appreciate it i've seen eric andre's
asked more than i've seen in my own ass
this [ __ ] is dummy thick though
yo
straight up dude my butt cheeks all
plump playboy i'm calling in thick to
work
will you slap my ass and call me baloney
um all these baloneys felt belonged
though let's [ __ ] update that what
the hell is going on here and yes i will
slap your ass and call you baloney
whatever you want i have no friends
eric andre please let me eat your butt
you know what she has away with words
she's a bit of a poet okay
where you at age sex location do y'all
think eric andre would let me choke on
his balls
jeez guys i'm a classy guy
and the answer is yes sit on my face and
queef in my cheeks
i actually take male clue it's when i
force air into my
coal and exhale it like a dragon's
breath
eric andre please come choke me and yell
random nonsense in my face
where were any of these people in
college when i couldn't get laid to save
my life i want eric andre to inject a
mixture of his common
rant in my veins jesus buzzfeed i
thought you guys were
little daisies over here boy was i wrong
i like it
sign me up when is the eric andre bussy
fleshlight going up for sale you know
what that's not a
bad idea legit me and my merch guy are
always trying to come up with like
outside of the box ideas like i
should get a custom mold of my booty
hole
and make a beduci fleshlight thank you
for that idea that's just
creativity right there you know i had a
very hard time getting
laid for the first 25 years of my life
so that was very validating and watch
the eric andre show
on adult swim thank you buzzfeed bye
love you
you